on long-term data with second-generation PTK inhibitors and CLL. These are my exclosures.
So we're going to learn much more about this from the next talk after me, but in the CLL17 trial,
this was a three-arm randomized phase three study in which patients with treatment-naive CLL of all
risk groups were randomized to ibrutinib, Veno, or I plus V. And in this study, this demonstrated
no difference in progression-free survival between either fixed-duration regimen with ibrutinib.
Now, importantly, for many, including myself, these data have been taken to imply that
fixed-duration therapy is clearly superior given the potential for retreatment to extend clinical
benefit. But this is not the title of this talk I'm giving, and so let's be honest with ourselves
about some of the things that we're going to learn. So let's start with the first one.
We have some limitations. We have very little long-term follow-up from the CLL17 study.
And so while many, including myself, continue to believe that this favors time-limited therapy,
it is possible that we see some separation in the PFS curves with additional follow-up.
We also have very long-term evidence of the first-generation PTK inhibitor ibrutinib in
treatment-naive CLL. We have data from the Europeans demonstrating similar,
overall survival between older patients treated with ibrutinib monotherapy
and their age-matched general population in Europe. We also have very long-term data from
Resonate 2 demonstrating a median progression-free survival of nine years. And so stepping back and
looking at the totality of the data, even for those of us who are very strong proponents of
time-limited therapy, it's hard to tell a patient that this is clearly the only option.
Or the best option for their disease. Really, any of the approved therapies that are
modern therapies in CLL are considered appropriate given normal expected survival.
Acalabrutinib and Xanubrutinib are second-generation covalent PTK inhibitors,
which are preferred based on randomized phase 3 trials in the relapsed refractory setting.
In the Alpine study, Xanubrutinib was demonstrated to result in lower rates of atrial fibrosis
dilation and superior progression-free survival when compared with ibrutinib.
In the Elevate-RR trial, Acalabrutinib resulted in lower rates of AFib and hypertension and similar
non-inferior progression-free survival outcomes compared with ibrutinib.
These data demonstrate that, again, the second-generation inhibitors should be preferred
in the relapsed refractory setting. And this has been extrapolated to the frontline setting,
which I think is very reasonable, in particular when it comes to,
say, the safety outcomes. Acalabrutinib was approved in treatment-naive CLL based on the
Elevate-TN study with very long-term follow-up now. Acalabrutinib alone or with obinutuzumab resulted
in superior progression-free survival when compared with chemoimmunotherapy with obinutuzumab
and chlorambucil. And importantly, when you look at the long-term responses over time, we see that
responses continue to deepen with longer-term follow-up. And so, in the long-term responses,
we see that responses continue to deepen with longer-term follow-up. And so, in the long-term responses,
we see that responses continue to deepen with very long-term follow-up, including beyond four to six
years, suggesting, again, that long-term administration of covalent BTK inhibitors
results in continuous deepening of responses in CLL. Xanubrutinib was approved in treatment-naive
CLL based on the Sequoia trial. This was a randomized trial comparing BR with Xanubrutinib
in patients without deletion 17 PRP53 mutations, demonstrating superior progression-free survival
outcomes with Xanubrutinib. And importantly, the Sequoia study included multiple cohorts.
Shown here is a large, dedicated cohort of patients with 17P deletion or TP53 mutation
treated with Xanubrutinib monotherapy. This was a recent analysis which paired these data alongside
that of Xanubrutinib monotherapy from the Xanubrutinib arm from the Sequoia study shown
on the previous slide, which did not include P53.
Demonstrating very durable progression-free survival with 60-month PFS of 76.5% for patients
without and 70.7% for patients with a 17P deletion or TP53 mutation.
And again, as with acalabrutinib, we see continued deepening of responses with long-term
administration of Xanubrutinib, including shown here in the high-risk patients with P53 aberrant
disease.
In total, if we look at all of these data, this really, again, reinforces that long,
long progression-free survival, that the second-generation inhibitors are safer than
abrutinib, and that this is including in patients with high-risk features.
So how do covalent BTK inhibitors fail? This can happen through one of two mechanisms,
either through progression or intolerance. Progressive disease can occur in the setting
of emergent resistance to Btk inhibitors, or in the setting of emergent resistance to Btk inhibitors.
So how do covalent Btk inhibitors fail? This can happen through one of two mechanisms,
either through progression or intolerance. Progressive disease can occur in the setting of emergent
resistance to Btk inhibitors, or in the setting of emergent resistance to Btk inhibitors,
most notably, most commonly in Btk. However, we know that many patients can develop resistance
and progression in the absence of a known emergent resistance mutation, a phenomenon that occurs
more frequently in the treatment-naive setting. Irrespective of the mechanism of resistance,
patients who progress on a continuous covalent Btk inhibitor cannot be salvaged with an
alternative covalent Btk inhibitor. These patients need to be considered for alternative
strategies, and they need to be considered for alternative strategies.
The second-generation covalent Btk inhibitors still result in some AEs that lead to treatment
discontinuation in about 10-15% of patients. These patients can be transitioned either to
an alternative covalent Btk inhibitor, a different class of therapy, or sometimes can be considered
for a treatment holiday. So let's look at some of the data supporting these decisions. We have
prospective phase 2 trials.
The second-generation covalent Btk inhibitors are the most common in patients with a covalent Btk inhibitor.
Most of these were previous abrutinib treatment. When we look at the specific adverse event that
led to treatment intolerance and discontinuation, 20-30% of patients will develop the same intolerance
event at the same severity, but higher severity events are very uncommon and very rarely lead to
treatment discontinuation. The second-generation covalent Btk inhibitors are the most common in
in these studies. What is the take-home? Well, it's appropriate to attempt an alternative
second-generation inhibitor in patients who have to come off for intolerance, but we shouldn't do
this for somebody who's had intolerance due to a severe life-threatening event, because 20 or 30
percent of these patients might suffer the same event with the same severity the second time
around. A treatment holiday can also be considered. This has been studied prospectively as part of the
FLARE trial, a study that has evaluated many different combinations and clinical decisions.
The FLARE trial included this cohort of patients treated with long-term abrutinib who were at six
years of abrutinib in an ongoing response and tolerating it just fine. These 112 patients
discontinued abrutinib electively on study, and at 12 months post-end of treatment, only five out
of 112 patients had clinical progression. Now, these data don't support routine,
timely, and effective treatment. They don't support routine, timely, and effective treatment.
I'm limited covalent PTK inhibitor therapy. This is not something I would endorse. However, in a
patient who's in a continuous, durable remission on a covalent PTK inhibitor, who's come off for
some other reason, say an intolerance event, or for an extended hold for a surgery or something
along those lines, I think it's very reasonable to consider a treatment holiday in these patients.
In conclusion, all of the approved covalent PTK inhibitors are highly effective in CLL,
with a second-generation inhibitor's
preferred in both the treatment naive and relapse refractory settings based on
high-level randomized data in the relapse refractory setting. In the treatment naive
setting, greater than 90% of patients will achieve a response to a second-generation
covalent PTK inhibitor, with responses deepening over time, including in patients with high-risk
features, such as P53 aberrant disease. A normal expected survival is seen for older patients,
really across any of the modern therapies. This has been demonstrated really just with abrutinib and
venetoclax, but I feel fairly confident that we could extrapolate this to other novel combinations.
And so, we should not be dogmatic about what is the one right therapy, but rather really be looking
at patients on an individualized basis. Finally, long-term follow-up studies have demonstrated
different forms of treatment failure with clinical progression on covalent PTK inhibitors, not
salvageable with an alternative covalent inhibitor, but something that can be treated with either non-covalent
inhibitors or BCL2-based therapies. And finally, treatment failure due to